and like now and the data just doesn't
support it it's like 50 of women are
going to be single and childless
it very much sounds like the life of sin
followed by a deathbed repentance no no
no no because there's a difference
there's like and this is one of the
distinctions you have to make and part
of why I brought up Jason Everett is
because what he said to me when I I
asked him this question on air was the
question you need to ask yourself is
like what could you tolerate 10 years
from now in a relationship with this
person and that is going to be partially
defined by that person's wounds the
things that they've done in their past
so a person having a very unfortunate
sexual history doesn't just or even
necessarily mean that they're gonna
cheat on you or be promiscuous they
could end up being monogamous and
faithful but they could still end up
having all sorts of scars with respect
to the way they view sex with the way
they view the opposite sex they can
become an angry nasty person because of
it and you want to know that there's
someone who has worked through it
there's no denying that it is better to
be a virgin right but not everyone is
and God calls people to marry
non-virgins as well